our business correspondent Helen and
Smith spoke to the chancellor Nadeem
Sahar with his reaction to the latest
GDP figures which show the economy has
shrunk by 0.1 percent in the second
quarter of this year he insisted that
he's doing everything he can for
families this winter
the next couple of months every bill
will drop by 400 pounds right the most
vulnerable eight million people get 324
pounds if you are disabled you'll get
another 150 pounds by the end of the
year if you're a pensioner you'll get
300 pounds by the MBA so that's still to
come still to come back for a second
hear me out for a second right that's
still to come now that was one part of
my job the second part from the fifth of
July with my leadership team I said
right we've got to work up options
because Putin is going to continue to
use gas prices as a tool to hit back at
us for the help we're putting into the
Ukraine and by the way he wants us to be
divided he wants to make this a domestic
division in the UK because we play into
his hands on that but what I said to my
leadership team is work up the options
of what we need to do to help people
through the winter so in December and
January we're working up those options
we're looking at what Headroom we have
to make sure we offer that additional
support my message to families today is
we will have those options ready to go
yesterday I met with the industry to
look at what more we can do with the
industry on Direct debit on prepayment
meters all the things that families are
worried about we're making sure we're
doing the works on the 5th of September
the new prime minister can hit the
ground running and get those things into
place lots of people will say Chancellor
that the people of this country elected
a conservative party to govern this
country this crisis is not weight will
not wait why should they wait until the
5th of September we're not waiting we're
not waiting that's my what I'm telling
you the 37 billion we're only Midway
through so in the next couple of months
we're going to see that reduction of 400
pounds for every Bill we're going to see
324 pounds for the 8 million most
vulnerable can I ask do you think given
your assessment of the situation that
direct grants to families this winter
are now going to be inevitable so we're
looking at extra directors all the
options of what additional help we can
deliver for families to get them through
the winter 37 billion is you know we're
Midway through that that actual delivery
the energy price cap Chancellor the
original purpose of it was to protect
consumers what now is the point of it
well as I said to you it continues to
help protect consumers but the reason I
brought the industry in yesterday was to
look at where there is market failure
where can we help more that would
actually bring the energy price gap down
there were materials the weight is the
set up fit for purpose surely it's not
when we're looking
the reason the industry uh came in
yesterday partly was to say okay what
what can we do together if there is
market failure for us to bring pressure
down on the energy price Gap and there
were material suggestions that we're
working up now ready for the new prime
minister on that